start with arizona do we just watch them
become one of the top teams in all of
football
absolutely i thought arizona showed a
tremendous amount of heart
um kyle murray man like if there was
questions about his leadership or him
being quiet
i mean i think he totally silenced a lot
of the critics um he went toe-to-toe
with russell um wilson
i thought he was tremendous yesterday
it just felt like he was using russ's
game
to beat russ in prime time the best
thing that happened
was this game got flexed into prime time
and have you seen the picture yet rodney
of tyler when he's in high school
wearing a russell wilson jersey
watching sunday night football watching
russ play and now he ultimately gets on
the same feel with them
and outshines one of the great
superstars in all of the nfl
i didn't see it i mean you got to show
it to me how can you bring it up and not
have a picture of it do you have a
picture of it
i do i i'll text it to you during during
the first question oh yeah
i think everybody else wants to see it
and now they've
now they've brought it back into the
fold it just it felt it feels like both
those guys are unsackable
how are they always able to even when
the pass rush makes it there
figure out a way to escape and go make a
little bit of magic
man that's that's what they do and
that's the thing that we talked about in
the pre-game show
not only have one spy for collar but
maybe have two spies and then just
making sure when you rush him you don't
get behind him you have to come up and
almost get even with him keep him in
this little box area
where he can't do his thing but the
thing that really just
i just loved about collar is when he
went off on the sideline he was yelling
and screaming at somebody and that's the
fire that's the energy
that you have to have and that's the
energy and fire that they were waiting
for
on this kid i'll tell you this one day
this kid is gonna be the offensive
player of the year
i i just like him man i just think he's
a really good football player
i remember the exact moment that you're
talking about rodney and it's funny
because liam mchugh
asked hopkins on the field before the
game what's something about kyler murray
that
you know regular football fans don't
know or don't get to see from him
and his answer was his command the
command of kyler murray and it was a
missed block
that you were talking about there was
like a tight end maybe two tight ends
out there that were blocking for a wide
receiver screen
they both missed the block and
immediately kyler dug
into him it feels like he has all those
leadership qualities
that maybe a guy like russell wilson
would have too
and it shows you too that they actually
respect the guy because if you get a
young quarterback yelling and screaming
at guys a lot of times guys would jump
back or say something really smart to
him
but that didn't happen you saw patrick
peterson come over and try to calm him
down but that's the type of fire
that you need if you're trying to win a
super bowl but one thing i want to
mention to you man is
we we can't go past that hustle play by
dk metcalf
and do you remember earlier in the year
when he was running he had the ball
and he was going into the end zone and
db came and knocked it loose you
remember that
oh yeah oh yeah and he came back and he
came back last night and just showed
everybody in the country
like what hustling and hard work can do
i thought that was one of the greatest
plays i've ever seen
rodney you know you've never been caught
quite like that in your career before
have you
when you got the pick six running down
the sideline
never i wasn't the fast i wasn't the
fastest guy but i tell you i was
probably faster than buddha
baker and i wouldn't have gotten caught
by him
is does dk look like he's just because
whenever you watch nfl games there's
fast and then there's nfl fast
and everybody knew that he was nfl big i
mean you see the picture of him with his
shirt off he looks like
like megatron times something else but
the speed element of his game seems like
something that
when he gets on the nfl field he makes
guys that typically are
outrageously athletic just look like
they're not quite compared to him
you know i saw him in the pregame and i
saw him in this cut off
short sleeve shirt and i saw him with
some real like short shorts
and i was just sitting there thinking i
was like could that have actually
like his body and the way he's built did
that work against him because the
patriots had an opportunity
to go grab him and a lot of times when
you look at a guy like that you say you
know what he can't play football
you remember david boston david boston
was a wide receiver back in the day
he was six one 240 pounds and a lot of
people didn't think that he could move
and
he couldn't play because he was so big
and i think it actually hurt dk metcalf
that he's so big and so physically
imposing
when you watch kyler murray play i was
because going into the game i'm thinking
you probably want to try to you know
force him to run around force him to try
to make too many plays
with his legs make some extra magic
happen but then when you watch him in
that game he is a
dominant pocket passer i mean from the
from the first drive or two of the game
he delivered that perfect deep ball over
the shoulder hopkins perfectly placed
then he came back throughout the course
of the game and hopkins about 10 catches
something like that
those two for not being able to play
together for long have a chemistry that
looks like they've played together for
their entire careers
brother i'll tell you this man just
watching them um they're going to be
together for
a very long time um and just
just to see the heart you know i mean to
to be able to be backed up in a
situation like that and continually just
always showing heart that competitive
spirit kyla murray won me over i i watch
him on tape and i'm like amazed at some
of the things that he could do
but last night truly won me over when it
comes to colin murray i just i think
he's a fantastic talent
and over on the other side it sometimes
gets lost a little bit when when you end
up losing the game you mentioned the dk
metcalf that one gets lost a little bit
when you end up losing the game tyler
lockett coming on in this game i mean
this this is as close to
from a wide receiver standpoint to a
perfect game as somebody can play wasn't
it
yeah and you you look what they have i
mean they have three
really really good wide receivers and
david moore he's been tremendous um
he's actually been each year seems like
he starts to get better
um what i like about tyler locket is
he's he's a small
guy and he can go deep but he's not
afraid to come across the middle and a
lot of
run after the catch catch it make people
miss
use that speed um but the thing that
really scares me about seattle is still
that defense even when jamal adams comes
back
i just i just think they don't have
great pass rushers you start to look at
some of the dominant teams like the
pittsburgh steelers like the baltimore
ravens
even the kansas city chiefs they have
guys that can get
to the quarterback you look at seattle
their best
pass rusher is a safety and he's going
to come back this week and it's just
in order to to go far in the playoffs
you got to
be able to have consistent pass rush and
they just don't have that
let's get it over to the cleveland
browns because baker mayfield
had essentially been written off you get
blown out by the pittsburgh steelers and
everybody goes all baker mayfield it's
the same
trajectory of him now regressing ever
since his rookie season he's getting
worse
he may not be the future of the
cleveland browns
i'm going relax i mean the next game on
the schedule is cincinnati bengals you
can go out there it's going to be a
little bit different
he took him all the way until the final
drive of that game to go do it
what did baker mayfield feel proved you
though this week
well i've always liked baker and i've
always thought that he was a mentally
tough guy and obviously there's
challenges when you're coming in you're
dealing with guys like odell beckham
trying to get him the ball and all these
different coaching changes and things
like that but for him to throw five
touchdown passes
it shows you that he can play we all
know that he can play
the question is can he do it on a
consistent basis the question is can he
do it
without the run game against some of the
better teams
we saw him against pittsburgh we saw him
against baltimore and he could not get
it done
but against your lowly bingos he was
able to get it done so i still think
they're lingering questions
as it relates to baker mayfield but i
tell you this
not having odell beckham and i know
that's a that's a devastating injury and
my heart goes out for adele because i've
been there
but i look at baker and i say and i'm
gonna ask you this
you think baker is almost in a sense
i wouldn't say relieve but do you think
this might work out even better for
baker knowing that he doesn't have to
force the ball
to odell beckham is that a stupid
question
you kind of we had the same conversation
going back to last week with the green
bay packers
right with devonte adams who had been
out of the building and aaron rodgers
was playing mvp form
and so those two things don't seem to
add up but it does
seem like it takes pressure off of a
quarterback when he doesn't have to drop
back and get a certain guy
10 12 targets every game you know it
just takes pressure off him because it
it really gives him the optionality of
where he wants to go with the football
instead of having to go to the sideline
every time and have a conversation about
why the superstar is not getting all the
looks
and it also gives your quarterback an
opportunity to develop chemistry with
the younger wide receivers rashad
higgins the tight end
harrison bryant donovan peoples jones
just to continue to get david and joku
involved and
that's you know it's not going to be one
guy just leading them they need to do it
by committing they have a lot of good
young
players and i just think the pressure
off of baker is going to allow him to
breathe
i mean you're never that you're never a
better team without
a guy like odell beckham but at the same
sense if your quarterback can have a
sense of calm and he doesn't feel like
that he has to force the ball to someone
who knows i mean he might become a
better player
and odell beckham jr he's not as young
as he once was
anymore so you have to start to wonder
about what his legacy is going to become
now two different teams bouncing around
a little bit
a whole bunch of injuries what does this
mean for
obj where he may go from here should he
be looking to get
off the cleveland browns where might be
a good fit for him or do you think it
will work in cleveland if he just lets
this thing breathe a little bit
i said this a week ago i said baker
mayfield will never be
happy in cleveland as long as baker
mayfield is the quarterback
because baker mayfield he's not that guy
he's not
he's not a guy that's going to drop back
40 times consistently and be able to
throw for over 300 yards he needs to be
in a system where he has a colin murray
or russell wilson
a quarterback like that where he can
really get involved and he knows that
they're going to be able to get him the
ball in cleveland
he's not going to be happy and i said
that earlier this year i said
they need to trade him to the patriots
or someone else that needs a wide
receiver because he's never going to be
happy in cleveland
rodney it does seem like we're losing a
little bit of appreciation just as a
football community
for the fact that the cleveland browns
are five and two you know like the
browns are five and two and we're
writing them off like there's some team
over
hanging out on the side if they were
five and two last year with freddie
kitchens
everybody would have been talking about
the cleveland browns or going to the
super bowl but instead now that you get
i mean it's a first year head coach
stefanski comes over
and immediately this is a winning
program are they as good as the
pittsburgh steelers
no they're not as good as the pittsburgh
steelers tomlin's been there forever
that's a built
ready to win right now football team the
cleveland browns under a brand new
head coach are already winning are we
overreacting to some of the
you know losses or setbacks that they've
had to get to where they currently sit
at five wins
no actually i think i think we've done a
pretty good job because we've looked at
the talent
we've been patient with them and we we
always say hey with this level of talent
with all the guys that they have
they should be able to compete with a
bunch of teams so if if anything
they've been a disappointment not us as
fans because
we've always appreciated the the the the
excellent football players they have in
the locker room
it's just our expectations always you
know they've gone up
and cleveland unfortunately they haven't
been able to meet our expectations just
like i talked about when you lose to
pittsburgh when you lose to baltimore
good teams no one's gonna take you
serious yeah it's
you can go out and beat the cincinnati
bengals but can you beat
good teams in your division and and they
they obviously can't right now
i gotta sneak one in on cincinnati
before we move on is that is that the
best one-win team
in football i mean it seems like every
single game they figure out a way to be
there
they look like they're gonna win it you
get confidence that joe burrow is lsu
joe burrow and he's gonna find a way
down the stretch and even in this game
against the browns he did find a way to
win it that was a hell of a
drive right there at the end of the game
great fourth down call to punch it into
the end zone and then it's just too
wild baker mayfield throws back the
other way is this one of the better
one-win teams in football or do you
think that
they maybe start to need to be starting
to think about who might be the head
coach of the future in cincinnati
no no no i think they're doing a great
job in cincinnati and you expect this
you expect some growing pains and
especially we talked about last week we
talked about
the lack of an offensive line and think
who knows during
you know this whole trading period will
they go and try to trade for an
offensive lineman
i know in the offseason that they're
going to spend a ton of money on the
offensive line because if you don't want
that young guy getting beat up you
better protect them
but no i feel good about cincinnati and
what they're doing
if if anything i feel better about
cincinnati almost in a sense more so
than cleveland
because i think joe burrow is going to
be a lot better quarterback than baker
mayfield
i i that that i agree with you on let's
get to this bergstealer show a week ago
it was the pittsburgh steelers that
demolished the cleveland browns the
steelers are now starting to get hot
steelers
beat the titans they're unbeaten so far
this season
and when you go and you watch them play
rodney three
great wide receivers this team has and
it's honestly hard to decide
who the number one is right now it
doesn't matter that's the great part
about this team
it doesn't even matter who's the number
one and ben he goes out and they doing a
good job of spreading the ball around
where you can't key on one guy he's
getting the ball out of his hands
quickly and they're using a short
intermediate pass and
quick passing game to set up the shots
down the field
james connor he's been terrific running
the football don't look at his numbers
look at his body of work and how
physical he's running the ball but i'm
gonna tell you this when i look at that
tape
every time i turn on the tape i see tj
watt
and to me tj watt i love aaron donald
but i look at t.j watt and i do believe
that he's lead he should be leading the
defensive
defensive player of the year award right
now because
he's playing a run he's sacking the
quarterback he's putting pressure
he's making plays from the back side i
mean tj watt has been tremendous
if you're a gm and you could draft any
of the edge defenders any defender at
all
in football right now how long would it
take you to pick tj watt where does he
rank among the best in the league
probably right right now the way he's
playing as
as a complete defender my first pick
would always be aaron donald my
second pick would be probably nick
bolson my third pick right now would be
t.j watt
wow okay so that's steelers defense in
general though let me ask you let me ask
you just exactly
jack let me ask you who would who do
your guys be
okay i i very quickly am going to lock
in on donald as well
tj watt probably number two for me right
now i probably go tj watt number two and
then khalil mack
number three although those are those
are you know 2a2b kind of a situation
that's
depending on the day you make your pick
uh right there what happened to your guy
derek henry this week by the way rodney
pittsburgh did a great job man and i'll
tell you just watching the tape going
back and watching the tape again this
morning what pittsburgh is doing
they're doing a lot of um linebacker
blitzes
run blitzes vince williams up there you
see how well he played and i wanted to
mention his name because he's been
absolutely outstanding
you see all these guys minka fitzpatrick
pick six last
last week and all these guys tj watt
um getting all the props but vince
william has been
absolutely a stud in the middle of that
defense you see his numbers nine tackles
of sack a quarterback hit
and just his physical presence on that
run game and that's what happened
derek henry met vince williams
that's what happened a week ago i took
camara as the top running back in
football you took derek henry as the top
running back in football
two different styles there camara
another explosion he had
this week he is a smooth looking guy one
of the most
patient runners that i've seen in a long
time and he also never really seems like
he takes
big hits he has a way of avoiding those
big shots which is rare for a top
running back
what stands out most when you watch him
play this weekend
well it's just the versatility in the
way they're using him i love the way
they're using them because they're not
over using him
they're bringing in latavius murray
giving him an opportunity
and they're using um alvin kamara
as a wide receiver so now he doesn't
just have to take the pounding of being
a running back but he can also use his
other skill set
as a wide receiver and he's been
tremendous i mean since they've been
doing that with the offense
he looks fresh he looks confident i mean
you see the rush yards i mean he's
averaging
almost five yards a tenth um and he's
got seven touchdowns i mean this is
another guy that
that could be in the running for
offensive player of the year i wouldn't
say mvp but offensive player of the year
when you watch the saints offense play
especially right now no emanuel sanders
no michael thomas
there's not a weapon that looks overly
confident you know
cooks maybe but when you when you watch
brees
there's only one option that he's
looking at first every time and it's
kamara
and they want to check it down to him in
the screen game they want to put him in
the slot bring him across the formation
just dump it to him
best case scenario on any down for this
offense
is getting the ball to camara in space
why
is it that none of these defensive
coordinators do like a boxing one
like a for basketball friends it's like
a box and chaser a running back spy
something to wear
every single play he is the singular
focus of the defense
to take him away and force drew brees to
have to push the ball down the field a
little bit
well i asked that for the last three or
four years with michael thomas
you know like michael thomas a hundred
plus catches every year
like why don't you double team him
especially on a third down especially in
a red zone
and no defense coordinator double teams
them and that's a question and i'm like
why don't they double team them and i
just cannot figure it out
how can you not worry about a guy that's
caught a hundred plus passes
you know receptions and an x amount of
years and alvin kamara you don't even
have michael
thomas to deal with alvin kamara you
know he's the guy how could you not have
one or two guys and jamming him and
beating him up at the line of scrimmage
i don't get it man i just think that a
lot of times these defensive
coordinators they look at their cards
just like an offensive coordinator and
regardless of the down and distance they
just say okay i'm just gonna play this
i'm just gonna play this
and that's what they do
and he continues to be the leading
receiver on the saints offense by a
substantial margin
even though you look at his average
depth of target it's about a half a yard
down the field
that's all they really do is just check
him the ball and then he
always finds a way the the really
strange thing about watching him play
is that it doesn't look like he's
running overly hard or like he's
you know using a whole bunch of energy
but he's always just moving
faster than all of the defenders it's
like such a patient
smooth looking like when you watch him
as a defender
why is it that nobody can tackle this
guy in the open field what does he do
that's different
than the vast majority of nfl running
backs well i think a lot of times too
when i'm watching a lot of defenders
they try to come up and get the big hit
on him and that's
one thing that these smooth guys they're
not going to allow you to do
you know they like he's very patient
he's smooth he has great instincts he
has a great
feel for where the defense is coming and
if you if
if he sees you're about to hit him he's
going to get down or he's going to get
out of bounds i mean that's smart
running you don't need him taking big
shots
and alvin kamar he's been fantastic for
this team hopefully
he can stay healthy when michael thomas
comes back um i like this kid um
um what uh um i forget the kid's name
i'm sorry
um the wide receiver mark cass calloway
that's who it is marquez callaway
um i like him and they got some guys
emmanuel sanders will continue to play
better jared cook he'll continue to step
up i think
jared cook is a huge weapon that i still
don't believe they use
enough jared cook is six seven how could
you not use him i know he caught a
touchdown
but yeah he's six seven why not use them
more
i'm with you trequan smith another
player that's stepping up pretty big for
them as well
let's let's stay on the topic of people
who just are not taking big hits
your former quarterback tom brady has
always notoriously
gotten the football out well before
anybody even gets in the radius
of an opportunity to have a shot at him
do you think tom is starting to enter
the mvp race
after the way that he played this
weekend
the mvp race um
i know tom's not worried about that but
tom's a very competitive guy and he
hears all the whispers and he hears
people talking about him and saying that
he's not the same player
i think for tom that's that's definitely
not important it's about wins but
you i would say tom is slowly but surely
creeping back in i mean i would say
who would let me ask you who do you
think colin murray or tom brady
if you had to choose between those guys
right now
i'm going tom brady i top brady played
about as close to a perfect game as i've
seen him play
in a long time and you think about this
offense
it's only going to get better i mean you
go through the weapons
godwin evans now a b enters the fold
scotty miller is the leading wide
receiver it always seems like tom wants
some receiver that nobody's ever heard
of that comes out
absolutely nowhere that is just quick
and it can win
in one-on-one situations but scotty
miller can run too i mean
he's getting crazy separation multiple
times multiple different plays one for a
touchdown one for a deep cross that went
for a huge gain
where he is stretching the field also
for this team and then you think about
a b antonio brown coming back and who
knows what version of antonio brown you
get but if it's anything close to the
last time we saw him paired up with tom
brady in new england
that duo was absolutely electric
together and it happened fast
you would think that they click right
back into what that was
and and that's and to me that's the
point will
will antonio brown come and will he
behave
that's the question will he behave
because when he's on the football field
one thing we know he
can play and i know he's missed some
time but once he gets back up to speed
on everything
like remember he's hall of fame caliber
so i don't i don't
like when i look at their wide receivers
i look and say
well if tony antonio brown he gets a few
games under his belt
he might be their best receiver that's
how deep they are
and the other thing too is you think
about how many
injuries their receiving corps has had
like this is great depth
this is a opportunity to provide depth
but you're providing a future hall of
famer you're
providing an pro as your depth
so i i like what i see and then i don't
believe bruce arians because i think
it's a bunch of crap
that he's saying that tom brady had
nothing to do with this like come on now
tom brady come on
like you know tom had something to do
with this
i i think tom brady's proving to be one
of the great recruiters in nfl history
right now
the way that he has put together this
offense with exactly what he wants
and just to bring back gronk to now
bring in antonio brown when he very well
could have gone to seattle
and also a super bowl ready team go play
with russell wilson that's a
win now program pete carroll dk metcalf
tyler lockett other guys that would take
attention off of them too
but i think he has a conversation with
tom brady and he's one of few
if not the only guys that antonio brown
in my opinion
will listen to because he trusts that
tom has the answers and over the years
tom brady has proven to have the answers
and now he's proving that he has the
answers
even with the absence of bill belichick
and so i think it's the perfect place
for him to go and i think
every time that any issue be it big or
small would come up
tom would have a conversation with them
you'd have them over to the house
whatever the case may be
and my guess is that it would be
resolved and i think that's why
you know if they proved that this
relationship could work in new england
why you would run it back
one more time in tampa bay yeah and
tom's
he's really the perfect teammate because
he's unselfish he doesn't make things
about him like when you look at when
when you talk to tom and you spend time
with him tom doesn't see himself
as the superstar the goat the greatest
quarterback of all time he
still sees himself as the six round
draft choice so there's a certain level
of humility that's there remember
he wasn't a first-rounder he wasn't a
first pick like colin murray he wasn't
a top 10 pick so he had the fighting
claw for everything
that he has so he understands the
struggle
and he's a great teammate because he
doesn't judge you he's just going to
embrace you
and he's going to try to do whatever he
can to get you on the football field and
that's what he did with antonio brown
and you talk about trust you talk about
the faith that they have in one another
and i think tom is the guy because
antonio brown has so much
respect for tom i think he purposely
will try to be
on his best behavior because he
appreciates the opportunity that he's
getting right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports